[Musique]
décembre c'est le mois des jouets il
s'en vend pour plus de 400 millions de
dollars avant noël chaque année au
canada
et pourtant 90 % d'entre eux sont
toujours faits de matériaux non
renouvelable mais beaucoup de jouets bon
marché qui sont faits de plastique qui
sont sur emballés et qui sont voués à
devenir des déchets rapidement par la
non durabilité de leurs matériaux et
aussi parce qu'il met sur un effet de
mode des jouets qui se retrouvent au
dépotoir et qui peuvent même être
dangereux pour les enfants
les études montrent que certains jouets
en plastique contiennent encore des
phtalates des produits chimiques
toxiques beaucoup de jouets
d'importation peuvent arriver sur nos
tablettes quand même sans qu'on sache
exactement de quoi ils sont composés
alors ça reste une problématique et
comme parents mais c'est intéressant
dans les trains formés plus de savoir
qu'on peut sélectionner les matériaux
plus rassurant c'est pour les rendre
plus faciles à trouver quirico landry a
lancé une boutique en ligne spécialisée
dans les jouets écologiques ou s'assure
de faire les recherches rigoureuses à la
banque de faire entrer en boutique des
produits qui correspondent à nos
critères écologiques tout simplement les
produits de voix ou de carton recyclé
aux emballages minimaliste et qui
participe à l'éveil des enfants
moi ce que je vous propose oui c'est
qu'on prenne tous ces jeux là oui et
qu'on les met au banc d'essai c'est une
très bonne idée on vérifie dans la vraie
vie là si ça marche
qu'est ce que vous en dites les
meilleurs testeurs ça restait nos petits
choux donc allons-y mettons ce banc
d'essai à lévis mélanie
[Musique]
voici margot vincent viviane julia et
billy rose
leur mission vérifier si les jouets
écologiques
c'est amusant
l'avocat voté hier ce petit arc en ciel
merci à empiler on l'appelle l'arc en
ciel où les petits tunnels il se fait en
bois de différentes couleurs
mais l'enfant de pouvoir s'en servir
comme d'un jouet a empilé il va pouvoir
s'en servir si on le met dans l'autre
sens comme des petits bateaux pour ses
figurines des produits québécois comme
on le disait ça nous fait plaisir d'en
faire entrer en boutiques notamment ici
une baguette magique conçu par un
artisan québécois plus que le quoi
[Musique]
est ce que tu sais pourquoi ces jouets
le sens différent non parce qu'ils sont
bons pour oi oi poids qu'il soit bon
pour la lune pour la terre nos testeurs
en herbe le confirment les jouets
écologiques c'est amusant mais peut-être
qu acheter un cadeau
ce n'est pas essentiel non plus peut se
poser la question est ce que j'ai
vraiment besoin d'acheter quelque chose
pour faire plaisir à quelqu'un je pense
à offrir une expérience des cours de
danse des cours de yoga des cours de
peinture des cours de musique on peut
offrir merci d'en faire une expédition
dans une cabane dans un bois on peut
faire toutes sortes de choses qui encore
une fois qui relève de l'expérience qui
favorise le temps partagé
finalement des cadeaux écolos c'est plus
facile a donné qu'on ne le pense il
suffit de savoir où chercher et d'avoir
un peu d'imagination vous avez fait des
belles rencontres ne le ratez rien
alors cadeaux écologiques il ya aussi
des que des cadeaux qu'on peut recycler
un des cadeaux qui ont une deuxième pour
éviter de devoir les envoyés au dépotoir
finalement je pense à l'organisme réno
jouets ils sont à québec ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils vont récupérer des jouets à
peu près 160 milles par année ça c'est
huit gros camion le par année là le
tiers vont être vendus dans leur
boutique à très faible prix mais le deux
tiers va être envoyée à d'autres
organismes de bienfaisance je pense à
moisson montréal par exemple on vous la
voyez la boutique juste ici morlende
jouets qui au lieu de se retrouver dans
les poubelles se retrouve dans de
nouvelles maisons avec de nouveaux
partenaires de jeu et si vous voulez
réparer des jouets que vous avez des
peluches par exemple qui serait éventré
qui aurait eu la vie difficile parce que
ça arrive à moi et bien je vous
conseille d'aller faire un tour à la
boutique raplapla ça c'est du côté de
montréal
ils ont ce qu'ils appellent un hôpital
pour les personnes de tissu avouez que
c'est quand même c'est quand même
amusant et là bas on va rafistolé
réparer des jouets et c'est pas que les
enfants qui vont là aujourd'hui la
propriétaire de la boutique me disait
que la plupart des consommateurs ce sont
des adultes qui retournent leurs
souvenirs d'enfance des jouets qui ont
40 50 ans et qui vont les porter et
d'ailleurs ce que je me disais aussi c
on a perdu cette faculté la de réparer
nous mêmes les objets écoutons là ya pas
beaucoup de grand maman encore qui font
la réparation externe non mais c'est
vrai des gens ne savaient pas trop où
est tournée pour les faire réparer puis
du coup depuis trois ou quatre ans on a
ouvert officiellement l'hôpital est là
il ya des tous les jours on a des
nouveaux patients qui arrivent
de montréal mais du québec dont dario
d'ailleurs aussi qu'on savait qu'on
avait une pénurie de main d'oeuvre on
savait pas qu'on avait une pénurie de
grand-maman well pour réparer des joies
au québec mais voilà plus informés
dessus merci beaucoup leur joyeux temps
des fêtes à vous aussi